[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well,
good afternoon, everyone.
Thanks for joining.
So this is 14.04, and the
title is Economic Science.
You'll see why momentarily.
So in terms of who we are,
I'm Professor Townsend.
I'll be teaching
the main lectures.
So what is this course about?
This is about not just theory
and certainly not just data.
It's about the combination
of theory and data
from the perspective of
economics as a science.
So in that respect,
it may be a little bit
different from classes
that you're used to.
It's not to memorize
theoretical material
and know which way
to shift a curve.
It's not just reading empirical
literature and discussing it.
It's the more challenging
and more fun job
of bringing those
two things together.
Background quickly, just in
case you're worried about it--
we do assume you've had
multivariate calculus as well
as basic economic
theory in 14.01.
There will be some use of
linear algebra, statistics,
and some language having to do
with algorithms and computing.
But you're not to worry about
that because if you are not
familiar with the
level that we need,
and it's not a very deep level.
In terms of the readings,
all the class readings
and the relevant
textbook chapters,
there's not one single
textbook for the class.
There's four or so.
But we carefully selected
the relevant sections
of those textbooks, and
you don't need to scramble
to find them because they're
on the class website.
So each topic in each lecture
has a set of readings.
One, two, or three will
be designated as a star.
And that's because they're
really the basis of the lecture
or provide key complementary
reading material.
You are responsible for
those in terms of exams,
and you'll need them
for problem sets.
There are other things
on the reading list,
recommended readings that I hope
you will engage in and enjoy.
And in fact, those
could be subjects
for discussion in Piazza.
We're going to focus on
theory and applications.
We're going to be using
empirical and theoretical
papers.
And ideally, we
are combining them.
As I was already
alluding to, this
is not an easy thing to do.
One has to learn how to do this.
And I'm sure you cannot
do it on your own,
so I strongly encourage you to
participate in the lectures,
and recitations,
and interactions.
But anyway, please
engage when you're online
and avoid texting, tweeting,
emailing, blogging,
et cetera, et cetera, shopping.
You may think that
you can multitask,
but typically quality of
learning would suffer.
So now we get into
the more fun part,
which is what are we going
to be studying in this class.
And I'm going to go over the
spirit of it, economic science,
and talk about the
economies we're
going to be
studying, and then go
through the syllabus in
a kind of a broad way,
not trying to read
everything that's there.
So I'm going to draw
on these authors--
Frisch for thinking about
economics as experiments,
Matzkin for a review of some of
the fundamentals of vocabulary
of econometrics, Angrist
for randomized and natural
experiments, Varian for big
data and the need of theory
for causal influence,
and Lucas on what
are models, what are
artificial economies, and what
is the role of
models versus data,
and how does
computation help us.
So that's just an
outline of what's coming.
Frisch opened his
lecture in 1926
with an article entitled "On
a Problem in Pure Economics."
And to quote him, he said,
"Intermediate between
mathematics, statistics, and
economics, Econometrics"--
he kind of invented the term--
"has as its aim to subject
abstract laws of theoretical
political economy or pure
economics to experimental
or numerical validation,
and thus to turn pure
economics, as far as possible,
into a science in the
strictest sense of the word."
Or to put this more
in layman's terms,
he's saying economics is
not just about theory,
it's about validating theory.
So just like the linear
accelerator at Stanford
bombards particles to see
whether the outcomes are
consistent with the
predictions, that's
our framework for thinking
about actual economies,
by running experiments
on them to validate them
and to do policy.
This is a graph from
Burns and Mitchell,
a book, On Business Cycles.
And if you look
closely, you'll see
these dates are pretty early.
They run from 1875 to 1900.
And as a business
cycle goes, it's
talking about depressed activity
versus upswings and so on.
And you can see
the ups and downs.
You might be interested
to know that the National
Bureau of Economic Research,
which is now housed here
in Cambridge, actually
began in Columbia, where
Burns and Mitchell
were working on this.
So Koopmans reacted to
Burns and Mitchell's book,
which was quite
famous and obviously
had an enormous
influence, arguing about
whether measurement
is enough, which
he says, no, we need theory.
And we need the whole
enterprise to be
about understanding
and utilizing
the framework for policy.
So there's a bunch
of quotes here
from Koopmans in this famous
article, Measurement Without
Theory.
He says, "The author's
scientific strategy
has measurement and observation
preceding, and largely
independent of, any attempts to
really explain" the variables.
But he, Koopmans, believes
there should or could
be more of a purpose--
that more is meant, namely,
a genuine explanation
of economic fluctuations,
with the idea that there
are a few extra economic
phenomena that are accepted
as data without inquiry.
But most of it has to do with
phenomenon being generated
by assumed behavior
of individuals
and the interaction of
the behavior in markets.
And then he goes on--
I don't know if this is tongue
in cheek or just soft selling--
"I am not sure whether a
still further objective
is included, which extrapolates
the idea of explanation
to prediction, within "the
narrowest attainable limits,
the effect of economic
policy on the movement
of economic variables.
He actually says, I feel
that prediction is actually
the most important
objective of the analysis
of economic fluctuations."
So again, it's not
just measurement,
it's measurement with
theory for understanding,
and with that baseline
conducting policy assessments.
Business cycles are still with
us, although this discussion
may seem a bit dated.
So I give you a
contemporary example,
which is measuring,
understanding,
and predicting the economic
impact of COVID-19.
And we will return to this theme
periodically throughout some
of the lectures.
Matzkin is about
econometrics, and she
delineates the ingredients
here quite well.
We have an economic
model describing
the agents who are involved,
their objective functions,
their information, the
way they're interacting.
The econometrician tries to fit
the economic model to the data
and has to make the
following distinctions--
first of all, which variables
in the model are observable
and which are unobservable?
Also, which variables
are determined
outside the model versus
those that are determined
inside the model--
exogenous versus endogenous?
Variables determined
within the model
are usually determined
by the choices of agents,
by their interaction
with each other.
The model also contains a list
of functions and distributions.
Some of these functions
are primitive, exogenously
determined.
They may be observed
or unobserved.
And others are determined
within the model itself.
They're not deep concepts,
but important to remember--
observed versus unobserved,
exogenous versus endogenous,
parameters versus functions
versus distributions.
Josh Angrist on running
experiments, as in randomized
controlled trial versus
quasi-natural experiments.
So he's referring here to a
genuine randomized controlled
trial engaged by
Fehr and Goette,
where they selected some
bicycle messengers to receive
temporarily higher wages,
and had a control group that
did not receive the increase.
And then you compare
across the two groups.
The study showed that
increase in wages
did make people work harder.
And because it was
temporary, it didn't really
change lifetime wealth.
So one is able to out the
impact of income changes
as opposed to wealth changes,
or in the jargon you'll learn,
we can identify the
intertemporal substitution
of elasticity and its magnitude.
But Josh goes on to say
experiments are time-consuming.
They're expensive.
They're not always
practical but.
This frame that we
use of experiments
is still very
helpful, especially
because human institutions
or the forces of nature
step into the breach and
provide natural or quasi-natural
experiments.
So an influential
paper by David Card
looked at the Mariel boatlift.
Fidel Castro temporarily
allowed free exodus of Cubans
to the US, and
they came to Miami.
There was a 7% increase over
a period of three months,
and that can be used to study
the impact of immigration.
Another example
is the destruction
of public housing in
Chicago, where they literally
were giving residents
alternative places to live,
and then dynamiting the
building and blowing it up.
And it's documented
that they chose
in effectively a random way
which building to blow up.
And so you can compare
what's happening
in public housing
that remains versus
what's happening to
the residents who
have been moved elsewhere.
And to a degree,
the financial crisis
also provides something of a
series of natural experiments
in banking.
So I'm not sure how
many of you have
heard this term, "big data."
It's quite widely used and
attracts a lot of attention.
And Varian is
talking about that.
Machine learning
specialists are primarily
concerned with developing
high-performance computer
systems that provide predictions
in the presence of challenging
computational constraints.
Data science is a somewhat newer
term, concerned with prediction
and summarization, but also
manipulation, visualization,
and other tasks.
However, the shoe drops--
most important area
for collaboration
involves casual inference.
Machine learning has
its part to play.
It deals with pure prediction.
But there's a difference
between correlation
among variables and causation.
And he gives this
example, which nowadays
is a bit more nuanced than
it was when he wrote it,
a classic example--
there are often more police
in precincts with high crime,
but that does not mean that
increasing number of police
in a precinct would
increase the crime.
In other words, what
he's trying to say
is which way does
the causality go--
from police to crime or
from crime to police?
And just seeing a correlation
between police and crime
in the data does
not tell you what
the outcome would
be of increasing
the number of police.
So Rubin who's an advocate of--
who's thought of as in
the behavioral group--
is actually in
agreement that we need
to think about the causal
impact of treatment
to compare outcomes
of an intervention
to what would have happened
without the intervention.
You can't do it alone with data.
You need some model to do that.
Lucas on artificial economies--
one of the functions of
theoretical economics
is to provide articulated,
artificial economic systems
that serve as laboratories
in which policies that
are prohibitively expensive
to do in actual economies
can be tested through the
model at much lower cost.
But he goes on to say
that to do this well,
it's really important
to distinguish
the artificial model economy
as sharply as possible
from actual economies.
So this is a bit subtle.
Insofar as there is confusion
between the statements
of opinion as to
the way we believe
actual economies would react
to particular policies,
and confused with statements
of verifiable fact
as to how the model
would react, then
we're not using the
theory effectively.
In other words, people
will make statements
about what they
believe will happen
as a consequence
of a policy change.
And the danger is
we may not know,
and they may not be clear,
if their prediction of what
would happen is based on data or
based on the logic of a model.
And then going on,
if we have the model,
we can see the
predicted outcome based
on the logic of the model.
And then we can go to the
data and see which statements
of opinion are accurate or not.
So that's Lucas's view of
the science of economics.
And in other words, instead of
being pushed toward what would
seem to be an attractive goal--
to make models more
and more complicated
so that they're more realistic--
Bob Lucas is actually
pushing the opposite point
of view, which is to earmark
them as artificial, potentially
relatively simple, so
that we can understand
the logic of what
the models predict.
Well, as I said, keep
them relatively simple.
On the other hand, economists
are getting better and better
at writing down and
analyzing models.
And one of the innovations that
has happened over the years
is not just the mathematics,
for which Bob Lucas is well
known along with his
economics, but also the ability
to compute solutions,
which he feels
is neglected in the
history of economic science
but which is, in fact, an
important consideration.
So you guys are
all MIT students.
I probably don't have to say
this, but we in this class
are also not going to shy
away from computational issues
when they arise.
And I will take you through
some of the algorithms
and share those with you.
Now I want to turn to the
description of five economies.
And they're also partly
representative of the kind
of economies we're going to
be studying in the class.
And then I'll get back
to economic science,
and we'll talk about how
we're going to analyze them.
So let me focus on
economies for now.
So the first economy, the
medieval village economy,
consists of about
300 households.
They can grow wheat with plows,
oxen, and of course, land.
But the land is
not consolidated.
The land is spread out
over the various fields
into long narrow strips,
quite fragmented--
on average, something like 30
to 60 strips for each household.
Second economy is a
Thai village economy.
Households are growing
rice and they're
growing it in paddies,
not in scattered land.
If the monsoons are
overly abundant,
households with low-lying
land will experience flooding
and households with land on the
rise actually do quite well.
But the opposite is true
in a medium to dry year.
The low-lying land does well
and the land on the rise
is subject to a drought.
So there's a lot of
variation, a lot of risk.
All households in
the Thai village
are obliged to transfer a
certain amount of their crop
to the local temple.
Buddhist monks run the temple.
Then the households with
low crops in a given year
can request an allotment
from the temple stocks.
And they don't even necessarily
have to repay right away.
That's a function in subsequent
years of whether they
get their yields back up.
And otherwise,
remarkably, there's
no borrowing and lending in this
village, just this institution.
The third economy is drawn
on a description of Oaxaca
in Mexico.
It's a set of
villages, not just one.
The villages are
separated from each other
by nontrivial distances.
Sometimes it's flat
land on a plain.
Sometimes there were
rivers, and valleys,
and other
topographical features.
Each village specializes in
production of a distinct good--
could be baskets, or pottery,
or textiles, machetes.
They produce a lot of that
good and relatively little
of the other ones,
but each village
values the commodities
which it does not produce.
And then trade occurs in a
series of regional markets.
The fourth economy is similar,
except that when traders
meet in these geographically
separated markets,
they're observe to give
up produced goods, not
for other goods but
for paper notes, which
are IOUs promising to
pay goods in the future
or pay money in the future.
So these notes are observed,
and used in exchange,
and circulate around
the regional markets.
The fifth economy is from
Malinowski's book Argonauts
of the Pacific.
It's another set of islands--
well, villages, but
they're on islands.
And they form a circle.
So typically, residents
of each island
embark in canoes on
trading expeditions,
traveling either in a clockwise
or counterclockwise direction
to the nearest island neighbor.
If they're traveling in a
clockwise direction, when they
reach the beach of the
island of destination,
they give up their cargo to
those neighboring Islanders
in a series of
elaborate ceremonies.
The goods go one way and
distinctive white-shell
armbands come back.
If they were traveling in the
other, opposite direction,
counterclockwise, and they
reach the nearest island,
they unload the
cargo and receive
distinctive red-shell necklaces.
I'm not making this up.
It's in the book.
These armbands and
necklaces are entirely
used for these
ceremonies, to prohibited
to be used for other things.
And it's very,
very rare for cargo
to arrive without the
shells and armbands going
in the other direction.
So at this point, you
may be a little worried
that we're about to study
villages and anthropological
works, but let me
draw an analogy that
is revealing about
the way economists
think about modeling economies.
Lucas-- the same Bob
Lucas I mentioned before--
talks about trees bearing fruit,
which is an agrarian metaphor,
but he didn't really
mean a village.
And Lucas doesn't like
villages very much, actually.
He actually meant
financial markets.
So a security is an
asset like a tree that
bears dividends like fruit.
So this is the
language that allows
us to go back and forth
from something concrete,
like a tree in a
village, to something
a little more abstract,
like financial securities.
One of those economies, the
fourth one, mentioned IOUs.
They were bills of
exchange historically,
and now they're called repos.
So these treasuries
used as collateral
to back loan, called
the repo contract.
And that repo will circulate
where the original borrower
becomes a lender,
and the repo contract
goes down the financial
chain, and then comes back.
And that strange Malinowski
economy I mentioned to you
is actually a close
analogy to Bitcoin.
Because Bitcoin tried to keep
track of histories of things
to condition outcomes.
And they realized they need
to "color" the coins in order
to distinguish more history.
Nowadays they do it differently.
But there was a
period where Bitcoin
was featuring colored coins.
And that's very similar--
the economics of that is very
similar--
to these seashells in Indonesia.
So I've gone all the way
from villages, if not
primitive economies, to not only
modern-day financial markets
but also to Bitcoin.
And I'm, in the class, going
to maintain and come back
periodically to a study
of Bitcoin of blockchains
and distributed ledgers,
thinking about it
as innovation in the technology.
So what is a distributed ledger?
A distributed ledger
technology refers
to the processes and related
technologies that enable nodes
in a network or some arrangement
to securely propose, validate,
and record state changes to
a synchronized ledger that
is distributed across
the network nodes--
a bit long-winded.
We'll come back to it.
Is it important?
Yes.
This from Harvard Business
School colleagues,
Iansiti and Lakhani,
a quote from them.
"Contracts, transactions,
and the records of them
are among the most
defining structures
in economic, legal,
and political systems.
Yet these critical tools
and the bureaucracy
formed to manage them have
not kept up with the economy's
digital transformation.
They're like a rush-hour
gridlock trapping a Formula 1
race car.
With blockchain, we can imagine
a world in which contracts
are embedded in digital code,
stored in transparent shared
databases, where they are
protected from deletion,
tampering, and revision.
In other words, the
entire landscape
can change with these
new technologies.
Although the Harvard
Business School colleagues
are trying to be neutral,
their enthusiasm is evident,
and there's a lot of
controversy about Bitcoin
and about blockchain.
So Satoshi Nakamoto-- we don't
know if he's real or not--
this is a pen name, presumably--
invented Bitcoin.
And in doing so, he
said, "What is needed
is an electronic payment system
based on cryptographic proof
instead of trust, allowing
two willing parties
to transact directly
with each other
without a need for a
trusted third party."
Well, this message was
not lost on central banks,
because Satoshi is
basically saying
we don't need fiat money,
we just need Bitcoin,
or Bitcoin can
replace Fiat money.
So you'll see the Banker
International Settlement
with statements like,
"Decentralized technology
associated with
cryptocurrencies, however
sophisticated, is
a poor substitute
for the solid institutional
backing of money."
Or Denison, Lee and
Martin, two of whom
are co-authors of mine
at the New York Fed,
"People do trust third parties.
They trust central banks to
provide currency and reserves.
And they trust derivative
payment systems that are run
by named and trusted
institutions--
he has in mind
commercial banks--
that maintain the ledgers
and the operating system.
Trustless, expensive,
decentralized systems
are not needed."
Many of these distributed
ledger platforms
promoted by the industry use
the word "disintermediation."
Now, if you view it
kindly, what they mean
is third parties are
extracting monopoly rents.
But if you're a
regulator and you
see someone trying
to disintermediate
the financial
system, you're going
to be a little bit
worried about that.
So it's a very interesting,
a very controversial area.
And every, I don't know,
five or six lectures
or so, we'll come back
to the theory and data
that we've been dealing
with, and ask questions
about Bitcoin, and
see what we can learn
through the lens of economics.
So I listed previously five
economies and the comment
that they're
metaphors, including
for the study of
modern economies,
including all the
way through Bitcoin
and things that are
happening today.
Here's a partial list.
We're going to study the
medieval village economy.
We're going to study village
India, northern Thai villages.
We're going to go from
villages to local economies
as in Oaxaca, in
this case Thailand,
to regional economies to
the whole national economy.
So we're as much talking
about nation-states
as we are about
individual villages.
In fact, we'll go
to the United States
and talk about local, state,
and the US national economy.
We will be looking at US
financial markets, as well.
Here and there we'll
talk about China,
which you might say started as a
village or a bunch of villages,
and has become a very
important international player.
So that's a list of economies.
Now, what do we
mean by an economy?
When we model them,
there is a systematic way
to do this that you will learn.
And that is, when we
write down an economy,
we mean to specify
the commodity space.
And within the
commodity space, we'll
talk about the preferences
of agents, their endowments,
and the technology
available to them.
So one way to remember
this is like a PET economy.
It is not the most favorable
way of thinking about it.
But PET is in preferences,
endowments, and technology.
And it is possible, when you're
learning the tools of how
to do the analysis, to get
so lost in the notation
that you'll forget
about the applications.
So I want to keep
coming back, even
on the early building-block
lectures, to the idea
that we have a common way of
constructing economies that
will allow us to consider
dynamics, allow us to consider
geography, and allow us to
deal with risk and uncertainty
as in states of the world.
So now, I want to be more
specific about what we're
going to be doing in the class.
And I'm going to do
this in two ways.
The first is to go
through the main headers
so you'll see the
content, and the topics,
and a bit of the methods.
And then I'm going
to come back and kind
of selectively look
at the smaller print
and make some auxiliary points.
Well, today is Lecture 1.
We're talking about
economic science.
Then starting
Thursday, we're going
to focus on the building blocks
for constructing economies.
As I said, preference,
endowments, and technology.
And we're going to try to
use that material right away.
So we'll be engaged
in conducting
some partial equilibrium
applications and experiments.
So the building blocks are
consumer choice, consumer
behavior, and production.
This is the traditional
way to teach micro,
but it tends to consume
much more of the course
than we will.
I want to get the basics
down and build on the basics,
as I have been saying.
But here, you may
lose track of the fact
that we're doing these building
blocks which we're subsequently
going to use when we're
constructing economies.
The next section,
Lectures 5 and 6,
talk about decision-making under
uncertainty, focusing on risk
and on linear programs
and dynamic programs.
And I'll come back
to that momentarily.
Then lecture 7
through 9, we finally
get to entire economies.
We'll develop a
concept of welfare
called Pareto optimality.
And we'll right away move toward
applications, risk sharing
and dynamics in
village economies,
including social networks,
supply chains, impact
of health shocks.
And here right away we'll
get into the impact of COVID
as a function of
whether or not there
are these insurance networks.
And we'll merge this with
supply chains and production
as in lecture 9.
Lecture 10 is about financial
accounts and management.
So it will talk about income
statements and balance
sheets, and household
financial statements
generally, and then also talk
about cash management, which
brings us to Bitcoin.
I promise Bitcoin in
distributed ledgers.
"Ledgers" means "accounts,"
so this is the natural way
to start talking about Bitcoin,
and ledgers, and management.
Lectures 11 through 12 start
to bring in obstacles to trade,
in particular private
information, where
we need to think about
contracts and mechanism design.
So we'll do this
in theory and we'll
add an application right away.
And we'll actually do
several applications.
Lectures 13 through 15--
these three lectures
are going to deal
with the definition of a
competitive equilibrium,
or Walrasian equilibrium, in
the general equilibrium setting.
And we're going to use
it for prediction, namely
what is the impact
of trade or tariffs?
What is the impact of
not only real, but also
financial liberalization
and repression?
We'll do that in Thailand
and we'll do it in the US.
Then lectures 16 and 17
deal with whether or not
competitive equilibria
are Pareto optimal,
and with issues of existence of
competitive equilibria and Nash
equilibrium.
These two lectures, 18 and
19, are a juxtaposition
of the micro and
the macro, the macro
being dealing with aggregates
from the top imposing
the structure,
basically from above,
versus juxtaposed with
the micro and the data,
where we can talk about
whether anything can be really
identified, talk about
identifying, identification,
and falsification.
And the last two lectures
focus on the failure
of the two welfare
theorems, which
have to do with whether
competitive equilibria are
optimal and whether optimal
allocations can be supported
as competitive equilibria.
Those two theorems
can fail, but there
are interesting
consequences of that.
Namely in those economies,
we have value intrinsically
worthless but valued money.
We can talk about the value
of Bitcoin, for example,
and other cryptocurrencies.
And we can talk about
monetary policy.
And indeed, we can
focus on bubbles,
and not whether bubbles are bad
necessarily, but ironically,
whether they're big enough.
So those are the
broad headers I'm
quite excited about the
class, and teaching the class,
and interacting with you.
Hopefully, going
through that, you
can see how much
material we will cover
and the importance
of the material.
But let me come back a
minute, without going
into the details
of everything here,
to let you in on a
secret of the strategy.
So when we get, for example,
right away on Thursday
to consumer choice, we'll be
talking about consumption sets,
and rational preferences,
and utility functions,
and properties of
various things,
which is extremely important.
But we jump into
an application even
in that lecture, which
is utility maximization
subject to budget constraints.
And in order to do those things,
we need our first major method.
So we're going to talk about
constrained optimization
and the use of
Lagrangian programs.
So the not-so-secret
secret is going
to be that we're
training, hopefully,
learning the
methods of analysis,
as these theories
and topics come up.
Usually in every lecture
or almost every lecture,
there's something
about a method that
will be very powerful that
I'll want you to learn.
And we will take the
time to go over it.
Consumer behavior,
which is Lecture 3,
is an elaboration on
the application, which
is what happens and
how do consumers
behave when prices are moving
and their incomes are moving
about.
So there's some
abstract stuff you
may have seen before about
normal goods and Giffin Goods.
Instead of just
memorizing that stuff,
we're going to go to an
actual economy, which
is China, where the
authors actually did
one of our randomized
controlled trial experiments,
and varied prices, and looked at
whether or not demand actually
went the wrong way-- demand
went up when prices go up.
And then we'll learn
some more tools.
We'll make this
distinction between
compensated and uncompensated
demands, duality, Slutsky--
doesn't mean anything
now, probably.
But again, we're building
towards statements
of if you had data, could you
use data to accept or reject
a model.
So the mapping from
the theory to the data,
as Lucas would have put it, is
happening with the ingredients
at the end of Lecture 3.
Lecture 4 is on production.
That's the second
building block.
And there we do production
functions, inputs and outputs,
return to scale.
But again, we jump
to an application,
which is profit maximization,
which is the analog--
firms maximize
profits given prices,
consumers maximize utility
subject to prices and income.
So we'll go through that
and derive some properties.
And then up pops another
method, namely, we
need something called
the Envelope Theorem.
So when we get there, we
can go over what that means.
And then we jump back, at
the end of this lecture,
to some fake economies.
Robinson Crusoe economy
is one of the economists'
all-time favorite-- an island
populated by one person,
essentially.
But that immediately leads
to international trade,
two-country examples.
And I'll show you some
work that Leontief
did on Input/Output
matrices that is actually
relevant for understanding
Google search algorithms
and for studying the great
East Japan earthquake.
And on this topic
of decision-making
under uncertainty, we will
talk about risk and measures
of willingness to get out of
risk if you had the option
to buy insurance.
So we will go through
some important concepts.
But then we will
immediately apply it
to the medieval village economy
that I've already referred you
to, and including
land fragmentation.
And then for methods we'll be
focusing on linear programs.
And that carries over,
not just to this topic.
But we will use linear
programs frequently
from this point on through
many of the other subsequent
lectures.
And coupled with linear programs
are dynamic programs, where
things are happening over time.
And the application
there is going to be,
why were these medieval villages
starving to death every 12
years, even though in principle,
they could be storing grain?
They didn't do it much.
And the method is going to be
dynamic programming and value
functions.
When we get to Pareto
optimality, of course,
we'll define what it means.
We'll talk about
the Pareto frontier.
We'll have our first
genuinely spelled-out economy,
an Edgeworth Box
Economy in the abstract.
I'll show you a way
to determine the set
of efficient
Pareto-optimal allocations
for any given economy.
And then we have another
tool, separating hyperplanes.
And I'll define it and
show you some pictures.
And then we go right
away to an example, which
has to do with
how would you know
whether an economy is really
efficiently allocating risk
or not?
In fact, the next
two lectures do
that in much greater detail,
going to Village India,
which I mentioned was one of
the economies we were going
to study, looking
at relationship
between consumption and
income, and then go back
to the medieval village
economy, and try to understand
whether the way they
were dividing up land
into those narrow strips
would or would not
be consistent with an optimal
allocation of risk bearing,
and under what circumstances.
And then we throw production
in there, as well.
So now we have risk,
consumers, and production.
And we'll talk about risk
and return, and risk premia,
whether they share idiosyncratic
household-specific shocks, what
to do about common,
macro-aggregate shocks.
And this part of the lecture
ends with the role of gifts,
the role of social networks,
and the transmission
of shocks in villages.
The transmission of shocks
is actually a health shock.
It wasn't a COVID shock.
But it does give us
a way of thinking
about the impact of COVID in
terms of impacting a household,
and whether or not they have
formal or informal coverage
to cover that bad shock, and if
they don't, how the impact can
spread around to other
people that they've
been interacting with.
And I don't mean the
spread of the virus.
I mean the economic
adverse outcomes
that propagate, not
the way the virus
propagates, but through
economic mechanisms.
When we get to household
financial accounts--
I mentioned this already
about five minutes ago--
we'll talk about
ledgers and management.
We'll talk about household
financial accounts
because we need them
to understand ledgers.
With the income and
the balance sheet,
we can talk about
life cycle management.
And I'll show you a wealth
planner, a life-cycle wealth
planner that we implemented
in Thai villages,
and show you an analog
wealth planner for the US.
Then we merge to
Bitcoin, for which
you need to understand
the statement of cash flow
and the relationship between
the flow and the stocks,
as in the balance sheet and the
cash flow, which will take us
to thinking about
alternative economies,
for example Thailand,
again, which
is still using paper
currency all over the place--
and we'll talk about whether
that's efficient or not--
to Sweden, which has
virtually no currency left.
It's a virtually
cashless economy now.
They're worried about that.
Instead of fighting
Bitcoin, they're
thinking about introducing a
central bank digital currency.
And we'll talk about that.
And Kenya is a poor
developing country in between,
where they have both
Kenyan shillings, which
is fiat money, as well as
an electronic money, M-Pesa,
which are claims on your
cellphone-- basically cellphone
accounts, cellphone credits.
And we'll talk about
some of the issues that
come up with distributed ledgers
in all those three contexts--
Thailand, Sweden, and Kenya.
We'll get to contracts
next, which has
to do with private information.
In terms of methods,
I'll share with you
something called the
Revelation Principle, which
allows us to append some extra
constraints onto things that we
did previously and continue
to use the same methods.
Here, we'll need some
lotteries to get the commodity
space to be tractable.
And in this lecture, we'll go
to those Harvard Business School
professors and talk
about smart contracts--
what it means, how to implement
solutions to mechanism
design problems.
This part, again, is
now, when you understand
contracts, the language of smart
contracts will make more sense.
We'll do both together,
and then we'll
have applications
studying contracts
in practice for small and
medium enterprise in Thailand.
In this case,
again, one of these
lectures where we combine
the theory and the data
together to make
inferences about what
the obstacles to trade are.
So then we get to the
Walrasian Equilibrium,
competitive equilibrium.
We'll define it, and
we'll immediately
apply it to the concept
of trade across countries,
the gains from trade--
or actually, who
loses, not just who
wins from trade-- and some
well-known theorems about that,
about the effect of trade
on wages and input prices.
With that theory in hand, we'll
go to two different economies.
We'll go to Thailand
and talk about villages
as small open
economies, what's been
the impact on them of increasing
trade within the economy,
the impact on them in
terms of the opening
up of the financial
system so that money
is flowing more easily, which
is the flip side of tariffs.
And there are losers
to liberalization,
just like there are
losers to trade.
So the thrust of
all of this is try
to use the model with the
data to identify who wins
and who loses from trade.
And then, obviously, we'll be
set up to talk about the US
in terms of the thing now
called the China Shock, which
is the rise of China, the
rise of China exports,
into Europe and into the
US, and the impact that
has had on various states that
used to produce goods, which
are now not so competitive
with Chinese imports.
Regardless of your view, you
can see the importance here.
Because what's going on
in the US and these policy
measures that are adopted
having to do with trade,
and which used to
be NAFTA and so on,
and now it's pulling out of
the Asia-Pacific Agreement
and having this
contest with China.
So we want to look
at those issues,
not from a political
standpoint but
from an economic
standpoint, to understand
what we know about the
beneficiaries and the losers,
and ideally try
to quantify that.
This section is
also about the data
available to do the analysis.
Sometimes we have far less
data than we wish that we did.
And in particular,
I have a section
which I have to
update periodically
on what is the impact of
COVID-19 on the US economy.
And again, we'll
go back to what's
the impact on income,
looking at income levels,
and ethnicity, and so
on, but also what's
the impact on the balance
sheet and on debt.
And we know some
things, but you will
discover that the
integrated data is not
available in the US.
So there are actually
surprising things we don't know.
Likewise, all this discussion
about inequality, how much
wealth the top 1% own--
that's much less
securely measured
than you might imagine.
And we'll go into
the reasons why.
And we have optimality
of competitive equilibria
in existence.
We have theorems-- existence
of competitive equilibria,
existence of Nash equilibria.
For the Nash
equilibrium, we'll go
to a model of US
financial markets
and try to analyze why
we see trade fails,
where those repo contracts
fail, and whether penalties
could or should
have been in place
to prevent those failures.
I think I said enough about
aggregation and identification
already when I went through
this the first time.
And we end with when the
welfare theorems fail,
but not stopping there.
The analogy with
pollution is to fix it
by selling rights to pollute.
We'll talk about how
to handle externalities
much more generally.
We'll talk about failures
of the First Welfare theorem
when there's dynamics and an
infinite amount of wealth.
And likewise, when
it fails, we'll
see the emergence of money--
both fiat money and Bitcoin.
One word about Bitcoin--
when the former head
of the New York Fed
referred to Bitcoin
as the adversary,
he was saying
something about there's
nothing fundamental pinning
down the value of Bitcoin.
Well, if you're
a central banker,
don't throw stones when
you live in glass houses,
because there's absolutely
nothing fundamental pinning
down the value of the
US dollar, either.
And the same model will
make clear that statement,
and hence, why it's possible
Bitcoin is volatile and danger,
again, for fiat money,
and remedies having
to do with monetary policy.
And again, the course
moves systematically,
so try to keep up.
Thank you.